S
THIRD PARTY, TO DO OR VIEW OF
THESE DOCUMENTS.
AND WHY ARE YOU COMING HERE NOW?
>> VERY INTERESTING.
IT'S GOING TO SEE, YOU EVAN.
THANKS A.
MUCH OVER ME, NOW JOHN DEAN,
FORMER NIXON WHITE HOUSE
COUNSEL.
--
FORMER FBI SPECIAL AGENT, AND
RYAN GOODMAN, FORMER SPECIAL
COUNSEL TO THE DEPARTMENT OF
DEFENSE.
NOW QUITE THERE AND CHIEF OF
THE JUST SECURITY BLOCK.
THANK YOU GUYS FOR BEING HERE.
RYAN, LET'S START WITH THE
VOTERS RESPONSE TODAY TO THE
TRUMP LAWSUIT EVAN WAS LAYING
OUT.
THE QUESTION THE JUDGE, RAISES
THEY SEEM PRETTY
STRAIGHTFORWARD AND SHOULD BE
ANSWERED.
I, MEAN EVAN AND I MENTIONED,
THE SEARCH WAS APPOINTED TO
TRUMP IN 2020.
WHAT DO YOU MAKE OF HER
RESPONSE?
>> I THINK POLITICAL DISCARDED
VERY, WELL THAT THE QUEST FOR
CLARIFICATION THAT SHE IS
ASKING DOVETAILS WITH ALL OF
THE CRITICISMS THAT WE HEARD IN
THE LAST 24 HOURS FROM LEGAL
OBSERVERS.
JUST SAYING THINGS LIKE, WHAT
IS THIS?
IT IS REALLY NOT WITH A LEGAL
COMPLAINT LOOKS LIKE.
IT IS A LOT OF POLITICAL
ARGUMENTS.
BUT IT IS ALSO UNCLEAR, WHY IS
THIS IN HER COURT, WHY DID THEY
FILED WITH THE JUDGE WHO IS
ENTERTAINING THE CASE AND HOUSE
ALL THE INFORMATION ABOUT IT?
IS IT A CIVIL SUIT?
WHEN WE ARE DEALING WITH A
CRIMINAL MATTER, WHAT IS THE
SPECIFIC RELIEF THAT WE ARE
ASKING FOR?
SHE IS PUSHING ON ALL OF THESE
QUESTIONS, AND THE SPECIFIC
RELEASE ONE IN PARTICULAR, LIKE,
WHEN YOU REALLY WANT THE
SPECIAL MASTER TODAY TO
IDENTIFY WHICH DOCUMENTS HAVE
OR A SUBJECT TO EXECUTIVE
PRIVILEGE?
THE SPECIAL MASTER IDENTIFY
THAT THOSE WOULD BE THE VERY
DOCUMENTS WHICH WOULD BE THE
NATIONAL ARCHIVES.
SO IT REALLY IS KIND OF A VERY
SIGNIFICANT REDUCTION IN A
CERTAIN SENSE, OF WHAT THEY
DID.
BUT GIVING THEM A SECOND
OPPORTUNITY.
>> OUR GOOD WAY OF SAYING,
HERO.
THAT LEADERS RESPONSE, AS RYAN
WAS LAYING, IT SEEMS LIKE A
SLAP ON TRUMP'S LEGAL COUNSEL
AND WITH THE PUCK TO GATHER
HERE AND PRESENTED.
THAT THEY WOULD SUBMIT THE
FILING OF THE LAWSUIT LIKE THIS
IN THE WAY THAT THEY DID.
WHAT DO YOU THINK OF THAT?
>> I THINK THAT IS ONE OF THE
ANGLES OF THIS THAT IS QUITE
EXTRAORDINARY.
IT IS REALLY HOW POOR HIS LEGAL
REPRESENTATION HAS TO BE, OR IS
RIGHT NOW.
WE SAW THIS ALREADY IN THE LEAD
UP TO JANUARY 6TH.
HE HAD HIS DREAM TEAM OF RUDY
GIULIANI AND SIDNEY POWELL AND
JENNA ELLIS.
BUT IT ALMOST FEELS LIKE HE IS
GONE EVEN LOWER THAN THAT WITH
PEOPLE WHO ARE NOT REALLY
PREPARED TO HANDLE THIS.
AND I THINK THE P HERE IS THIS
REALLY LOOKS LIKE IT IS HEADED
IN THE DIRECTION OF A POTENTIAL
INDICTMENT.
AND TRUMP REALLY NEEDS TO HAVE
A STRONG LEGAL REPRESENTATION
FROM EXPERIENCE LAWYERS WHO
KNOW HOW TO DEFEND A CRIMINAL
CASE.
BEYOND THEY HAVE TO AT LEAST
KNOW HOW TO FILE DOCUMENTS IN
COURT.
AND I THINK THERE NEEDS TO BE A
TIME WHEN YOU REPRESENTED THE
PRESIDENT WOULD MAKE YOUR LEGAL
CAREER.
AND THE PIERS THAT NOBODY WANTS
TO REPRESENT HIM, PARTLY
BECAUSE HE IS A BAD CLIENT AND
HE DOES NOT LISTEN TO ADVICE.
HE DOES NOT PAY HIS LAWYERS.
AND OFTEN THE LAWYERS AND UP
UNDER INVESTIGATION, IN SOME
FORM THEMSELVES.
SO, YOU KNOW, I DON'T KNOW WHAT
TO SAY BUT IT DOES NOT LOOK
GOOD FOR TRUMP AT THIS POINT.
>> I WOULD SAY, ASHA, YOU SAID
A LOT.
YOU SAW THE.
WHAT JOHN, THEN THERE IS THIS
RELEASED LETTER THAT THE
ARCHIVES AND TRUMP BACK IN MAY
ABOUT THE MORE THAN 100
CLASSIFIED RECORDS AND 700
PAGES OF THE RETREAT FROM HIS
HOME EARLIER IN THE EAR.
THE FORMER AT ONE OF TRUMP'S
CHIEF OF STAFF, THE FORMER
ACTING CHIEF OF DR. MICK
MULVANEY, HE TOLD ME EARLIER
TODAY THAT THE SHEER VOLUME
DOES NOT CONCERN HIM AS MUCH,
BECAUSE PEOPLE LISTEN TO THEIR
WALKING OR CLASSIFY DOCUMENTS
ALL OF THE TIME, I THINK IT IS
GOOD STUFF TODAY BOXES THERE
MOVING OUT OF THE WHITE HOUSE.
IS THAT HOW YOU SEE IT?
>> I REALLY DON'T SEE IT THAT
WAY.
I THINK PARTICULARLY SPECIAL
ACCESS PROGRAM DOCUMENTS ARE
GENERALLY NUMBERED AND
MONITORED QUICKLY.
THEY ARE CLOSELY WHERE THEY ARE
AND WHO HAS THEM.
ALONG WE HAVE HAD THEM, THE
PRESIDENT HAD THEM THEY WOULD
KNOW WHERE THEY ARE.
THAT IS WHY ONE OF THE REASONS
THE FBI BEGAN LOOKING AT THIS
THEY RECOGNIZED DOCUMENTS WERE
MISSING BECAUSE THEY HAVE A LOT
OF THESE DOCUMENTS WERE NOT
RETURNED.
SO THIS LETTER IS VERY TELLING
AND IT IS NOT JUST RELEASED BY
THE NATIONAL ARCHIVES, IT WAS
RELEASED IN RESPONSE TO JOHN
SOLOMON,, WHO POSTED HIS FORM
ON HIS WEBSITE.
AND THEY WANTED TO PUT OUT THE
ORIGINAL SO WE CAN ALL SEE WHAT
WASN'T IT.
IT IS A VERY DAMNING LETTER FOR
THE TRUMP PEOPLE, AND THE
DETAIL IT EXPLAINS OF HOW THEY
DIDN'T DO ANYTHING FOR A YEAR
OR MORE BEFORE THE ARCHIVES
FINALLY DECIDED THEY HAD TO ACT.
IT TELLS THAT THEY RELEASED IT,
SOLOMON RELEASED IT, TO TRY TO
ACCUSE THE BIDEN ADMINISTRATION
OF POLITICIZING THIS
INVESTIGATION.
THE LETTER SHOWS EXACTLY THE
OPPOSITE, IT SHOWS THAT THE
ARCHIVES WENT BY THE BOOK, THEY
HAD TO GO TO THE JUSTICE
DEPARTMENT.
THIS WAS SO EXTREME.
JUSTICE FOLLOW THE PRESIDENTIAL
RECORDS ACT, WENT TO THE WHITE
HOUSE.
THE WHITE HOUSE ACTUALLY SAID,
LISTEN, WE WILL DEFER TO THE
ARCHIVES ON MAKING THESE
DECISIONS.
SO THIS IS NOT BIDEN AND
THEY'RE TRYING TO PROVOKE THIS
INVESTIGATION.
I THINK THAT IT IS AN IMPORTANT
LETTER, IT IS AVAILABLE ONLINE
FOR PEOPLE WHO ARE FOLLOWING
THIS INVESTIGATION.
AND I THINK THEY WILL LEARN A
LOT FROM IT.
>> RYAN, FROM A LEGAL
STANDPOINT, BRINGING A LITTLE
BIT, TRYING TO BRING IT ALL
TOGETHER, WHY DOES IT
CONTRIBUTE, I WANT BURYING YOU
THINK THE NUMBER, 700 PAGES OF
CLASSIFIED DOCUMENTS THEY HAVE
TAKEN SINCE JANUARY IN THE
SELECTION OF BOXES FROM
MAR-A-LAGO, WOULD THAT HAVE ON
THE DECISION FOR THE JUSTICE
DEPARTMENT BRINGING IN CHARGES?
>> I DO THINK IT IS A
BREATHTAKING NUMBER.
700 PAGES JUST IN THE FIRST
TRANCHE, 100 DOCUMENTS.
WE KNOW THAT THERE WERE --
THREE AND DOCUMENTS BASED ON
THE NEW YORK TIMES REPORTING.
THAT IS A HUGE.
NUMBER I THINK IT INFLUENCES
THE JUSTICE WROTE IN THE NUMBER
OF WAYS.
FIRST, IT IS A STRONG
INDICATION THAT THIS IS NO
MISTAKE.
JUST BY THE WAY COUPLE OF
DOCUMENTS, THAT IS A VERY LARGE
VOLUME ESPECIALLY WHEN WE ARE
TALKING ABOUT DOCUMENTS AROUND
--
SOME OF THEM ARE COLOR CODED IN
THE REST, YOU DO NOT MISS ON
YOUR FILINGS.
AND THEN THE SECOND, IS I THINK
IT MEANS THAT THERE ARE VERY
SIGNIFICANT STATIONS FOR THE
NATIONAL SECURITY.
ALL OF THAT SHOULD BE DIFFICULT
FOR THE JUSTICE PROPERTY TURNED
AWAY FROM, IF THEY'RE THINKING
ABOUT WHETHER NOT TO BRING AN
INDICTMENT.
AND I THINK THE PROSECUTORS
WOULD SAY LOOK, THIS IS
WINNABLE.
WE CAN CONVINCE A JURY WITH A
NUMBER THAT IS SO BREATHTAKING
IT WILL STICK IN THE MAJORITY'S
MIND.
IN TERMS OF NATIONAL SECURITY
IMPLICATIONS AND THE QUESTION
OF HOW WILLFUL IT WAS ON THE
PART OF THE PRESIDENT TO HAVE
THESE DOCUMENTS.
>> I WANT TO ASK, YOU ASHA
RANGAPPA, ABOUT THE SCREEN
IMPLICATIONS.
THE NATIONAL ARCHIVES EXPLAINED
THEY GOT TO THIS IN THIS LETTER
THAT THE JUSTICE DEPARTMENT,
PART OF THE REASON HERE IS THAT
WE JUST A STORM IN THE WAY THEY
PUT IN THE LETTER, WANTED TO
CONDUCT AN ASSESSMENT OF
POTENTIAL DAMAGE RESULTING FROM
THE APPARENT MANNER IN WHICH
THESE MATERIALS WERE STORED AND
TRANSPORTED, ANTIGONE IS SORRY
REMEDIAL STEPS.
YET WE KNOW THAT TRUMP, FROM
WHAT WE KNOW ABOUT THESE MORE
RECENT FBI SEARCHES OF
MAR-A-LAGO, STILL HAVE MORE
CLASSIFIED DOCUMENTS.
WHAT IS YOUR TAKE FROM THAT?
>> THERE ARE TWO TAKEAWAYS.
FIRST, WITH THE ON SECURE
POSSESSION OF THESE DOCUMENTS,
THE GOVERNMENT HAS TO BASICALLY
OPERATE ON THE ASSUMPTION THAT
SOME UNAUTHORIZED THIRD-PARTY
HAS SEEN THEM.
AND BY THE WAY, JUST IN TERMS
OF HIS LAWYERS AND --
I KNOW THERE IS PARTIES HAVE
SEEN THEM, BUT LET'S SAY A
FOREIGN INTELLIGENCE SERVICE
HAS GOTTEN ACCESS TO THEM IN
SOME WAY.
MAR-A-LAGO IS ACTUALLY OPEN TO
TRAFFIC.
IT WOULD BE A TARGET FOR THEM.
THEN THEY HAVE TO GO BACK AND
LOOK AT PROTECTING SOURCES AND
METHODS.
ENGAGING THEIR COUNTER
INTELLIGENCE RESOURCES TO SEE
WHETHER OUR OTHER ENTITIES KNOW
THINGS THAT THEY DO NOT KNOW,
AND TAKING MEASURES TO PROTECT
AGAINST THAT.
BUT THE OTHER PIECE OF THIS IS
THAT TRUMP APPEARS TO BE
WILLFULLY EVADING THE
GOVERNMENTS ATTEMPT TO RECOVER
THIS.
IT IS NOT THAT IT TOOK A, YEAR
AND HE, SAID OKAY OKAY HERE TO
GET ALL BACK.
I MEAN, THE NEW YORK TIMES
REPORTING SAYS THAT HE ACTUALLY
WENT THROUGH THE DOCUMENTS THAT
HE GAVE BACK, IN THOSE 15
BOXES.
WHICH I WOULD INTERPRET, AS HE
WANTED TO MAKE SURE THAT HE WAS
NOT COMING BACK SOMETHING HE
REALLY WANTED TO KEEP.
AND, THEN EVEN AFTER THE
SUBPOENA WAS SERVED AND THEY
CAME IN YOUR FEARS THOSE
DOCUMENTS, HE COULD CONTINUE TO
HOLD ON TO STAFF.
SO I THINK WE NEED TO ASK, WHY
IS HE HOLDING ON TO?
WHAT WAS HE HOLDING ON TO?
AND WHY?
WHAT WAS THE IMPORTANCE OF THIS
TO HIM?
WHAT KIND OF COMPROMISE HAS
THAT MADE FOR NATIONAL SECURITY?
>> THIS DOES KIND OF CIRCLE
BACK TO A BASIC QUESTION FROM
THE VERY BEGINNING OF THIS,
THAT HAS NOT YET BEEN ANSWERED.
WHICH AUTO JUST GOT, TO.
JOHN WHICH, IS WHY DID DONALD
TRUMP TO HAVE THESE, WHEN HE
HAD THE ONE THEY WANT TO KEEP
THEM.
THAT IS STILL NOT KNOWN.
>> ABSOLUTELY, AND WE HAVE A
TRUMP WESTERNER IN MAGGIE
HABERMAN, WHO HAS DONE HER BEST
TO TRY TO EXPLAIN HER
UNDERSTANDING, FROM WHAT SHE
HAS BEEN ABLE TO PICK UP, BUT
HE JUST WANTS THESE DOCUMENTS.
HE LIKES TO SHOW OFF STUFF AND
SHOW PEOPLE DOCUMENTS.
THESE ARE NOT THE SORTS OF
THINGS THAT YOU WANT TO HAVE
AROUND FOR THAT PURPOSE.
AND I THINK THAT IS WHERE THE
GOVERNMENT IS WORRIED ABOUT.
WHO DOES HE SHOW IT, TO WHERE
ARE THEY, HAVE PICTURES BEEN
MADE OF THEM.
AND THINGS OF THAT NATURE.
HE JUST WANTS TO BE A BIG DEAL
AND THE CENTER OF ATTENTION.
THIS IS THE WRONG KIND OF
MATERIAL HE USES FOR THAT
PURPOSE.
>> KNOWING OTHER TWO BIG
HEADLINES COMI